Hello, friend.
Let us go on an adventure.
It will be much fun.
Do it.
These look like more friends.
I will say hello.
They did not respond well.
You will be my friend.
(OMG YES PLS)
(MY SPLEEN HURTS)
You will be my friend.
(I AM A NEW MAN)
(ALL HAIL BABY)
All will be my friend.
[DAT ASS]
Still not enough friends.
I see you.
I must have more friends.
I must become...
...friendlier.
It has begun.
Soon all will feel my friendliness.
Hello again, friend.
Shall we begin.
My friendship is strong.
My friendship is PAIN.
My friendship is eternal.
My friendship is eternal SUFFERING,
(OMG UR FRIENDSHIP SO HAWT)
My friendship is forever.
My friendship is MAGIC.
What a lovely dinner for friendship.
What a lovely death for friendship.
I now have enough friends.
I must return to my people.
Ow! Tree!
Goodbye, friend.
I shall always remember you...
...as my first friend. ;3
I got really bored.
I'm sorry.
NOT SORRY!